and uh we have a result  and of course giri did lose to shakira  so shakaria picks up an important three  points  so  that will take  mama jarv up to  11 points i think on the standings let's  have a look  spirited debate there yeah 11 and a half  points  yeah it was just a impractical decision  to play into that endgame  and you can see it just cost an ish  the time  and also he just could not find the  accurate way to defend  yeah with hindsight it's very surprising  that he played rook 88 so quickly after  which this whole sequence is forced when  he had to defend his end game which was  fine maybe  i would think he knows everything  probably that's  a stretch here but maybe even knew that  was equal but here black has a bunch of  moves i have the computer running  computer says bishop a6 for